yes this interview is awesome but what's
even more awesome if you click this box
is the extended 45 minute uncensored
uncut portion of the interview that
never ran on terrestrial radio or on
this channel it's over at Milo's channel
enjoy I have to ask the Mariah Carey is
that the gay team Jersey for English
people like Celine is for the gay people
in Quebec yeah I mean it's just it's
just I say I like here I have no idea if
I really do our next guest on he's
actually writing a book on something
many of you may not know about some of
you do online you probably know in
terrestrial radio some of you don't know
but this is the guy with whom you should
speak my lowly innopolis book on what's
the title for the book Milo well the
working title is just gamergate which is
the name of the controversy but it's
dependent on my publishers they may want
to give it a sexed-up title at the
moment is just gamergate ok detecting an
accent polish yes yes nicely from the
Ukraine no no I'm from London dialing in
from my spare bedroom in London I didn't
know you guys get in out there so Milo
didn't we invent it along with
everything else I mean come on along
with the language you're speaking give
me a break here's my problem though and
we've had Paul Joseph Watson on about
this yes he's from the north I mean he
is from somewhere with no internet they
barely have running water up there I'm
from civilization down south let's find
him so northern England is kind of like
Quebec is to Canada is that what you're
saying I'm not from well I mean Kubek is
for the French people so nothing could
be worse than that but no I think the
maratha the north of England is probably
more like Detroit maybe or I don't know
somewhere really barren and hopeless and
and just oh god somewhere this just
manage decline ok great great start for
a home station in Detroit well ok so
Milo anyways all I was going to say is
my problem as you do speak English
properly you just don't pronounce your
R's and if you invented the language
find someone who can teach you the arse
Milo game
okay a lot of people don't really know
what this is when they get the wrong
focus so I don't want to put words in
your mouth but this is something that
I've been following online and I see it
as an incredible opportunity to fight
back against honestly we have the
language police where I was raised in
Quebec the actual police language but
let police day long anyways now I'm
sorry I'm offending you with the French
please don't hit the shut off oh I know
no I know about this they are the the
Academy forces in Paris which attempts
to regulate the French language okay why
bother right yes and a lot of
similarities now with the politically
correct sort of I guess you'd say pseudo
language police in the United States I
see a lot of that with gamergate a
really strong rejection but I know it's
about ethics and journalism again I
don't want to put words in your mouth so
you go educate the room everybody know
if you want know I mean the interesting
thing about the gamergate controversy
the reason I think it's significant the
reason I think it matters to people who
don't play video games and who don't
care about video games is that the
gamers have been the first fandom the
first community to not only to fight
back against the language police the
social justice warriors the feminists
the censors the trendy metropolitan
liberal bloggers on the east and west
coasts the neurone only been the first
community to fight back they've been the
first community to win they are winning
those battles the bloggers concerned of
how to give sort of grudging admissions
of their conflicts of interests the
feminists now are sort of running but
with their tails between their legs
admitting that maybe they've got it
wrong and oh they're sorry for the only
thing that's been nice if you're not
wrong the feminists some of them of
course used to be men but you know the
the issue is that not only did gamers
take them on but game is won and they
provided a really interesting template
for other fandoms and for other sorts of
people to fight back and basically what
it teaches us is what I think we've
known all along which is if you don't
give in if you don't budge if you don't
give an inch if you don't say oh god
we're sorry we did this poster with a
sexy woman on it it's really offended
everybody if you if you stand your
ground your consumers your customers
will reward you for it and the potential
benefits are not just financial but also
reputational the only thing you can do
wrong in the face of the sort of
feminism social justice warrior
incursion the only thing you can do
wrong is given and gamers have
demonstrated this with sort of fortitude
and thoroughness and extraordinary
meticulous attention to detail in their
campaigns and all the rest of it like
we've never seen before and it's been
remarkable thing to watch video games is
an 87 billion dollar industry bigger
than Hollywood it is going to be a very
significant part of the way that people
communicate the way people enjoy
themselves the way they relate to other
human beings so very significant and
very important it's a very important art
form it's a very important cultural
movement and and you know people of my
children's generation will keep
communicate with one another and will
come to find out about the world in
large part through through gaming's
through a gaming of some kinds of video
games of some kind and sort of nipping
about this poisonous ideology which is
so thoroughly and completely and
effectively infected literature comic
books sci-fi fantasy to stand up to
these people and say you know what no
what you're saying is nonsense it's
based on tired discredited 70s identity
politics and you know ridiculous
ideology that you know fill out a
fashion in academia decades ago what
you're saying is nonsense you are
calling people names who don't deserve
to be called names you're dragging
people's names through the mud there is
no basis for any of the claims that
you're making get out of our hobby for
the first time it's starting to work and
I think gamers deserve some credit for
that and if somebody is interested in
the culture wars and is interested in
you know battlegrounds of this type the
gamergate controversy has been by far
the most interesting one I've
encountered in the last 8 10 years you
know it's fascinating you talk about
that because you have two different sort
of factions people saying well don't
bring it to the feminist issue this is
about ethics and journalism it's sort of
a gamer version of you know journalist
which I know you work with you've done
some work with Breitbart Andrew right
that's a big pardon in review so I know
that the two kind of intersect but I
think people missed that that bigger
point I think it's because a lot of
gamers aren't inherently conservative
like I am and I think conservatives
maybe have a disconnect there they're
starting off from the platform of you
know life liberty pursuit of happiness
and I think gamers are experiencing the
wrath of sort of this politically
correct monster that many of them don't
even realize they've helped they've
helped create well what's interesting
about gamers gaming is
the medium I think is a naturally
libertarian medium it's mostly about
personal agency and the consequences of
one's own actions
it's about self-sufficiency it's a
shouting hookers and of course shooting
hookers which you all love to do on the
screen unless a Charlie Sheen continued
well you know and I think it's an
inherently libertarian medium and the
the the war opening up for me is not so
much between left and right as between
authoritarians and libertarians I very
much see what I see happen easy MERS who
are instinctively left-wing they think
hold on one second geez I didn't realize
we have to go to a break oh let's
probably keep the lights on and then
I'll bring you right back
Mylo of gamergate fame ladder with
Cotter stay tuned back with Milo writing
a title writing a book sorry on
gamergate huge scandal actually in one
of the biggest industries not only the
United States in the world so it's
important to talk about Milo I had to
cut you off the floor is yours sir
continue yeah sure what I was saying is
that the biggest gap for me is not
between the left and the right in this
in this war
I think gamers think of themselves as a
reflexively left-wing and I think
they're right - certainly with surveys
they do show that their left-wing on
most social and many economic issues the
gap for me the interesting gap and I
think it's one that's opening up
throughout society is between
authoritarianism and libertarianism I
think it's between people who want to
dictate how others live and people who
simply want to be left alone our game is
very firmly fall into that second box of
people who want to be left alone that's
why in many cases they're playing games
in the first place
so they've reacted very strongly against
the people who want to tell them what's
acceptable and what's not in their games
and I don't think it really matters
where those points have you come from
and what's interesting about the social
justice warriors like I need to
sarkeesian is just how much they have in
common with the old religious right
almost indistinguishable for example
from Jack Thompson who said that video
games are very violent Anita sarkeesian
says they're sexist and these critics
use the same tactics they demand the
same things they use the same language
and to alter medicine purposes they are
indistinguishable from one another
social justice warriors and feminists of
course hate this being pointed out to
them but it is nonetheless true and so I
think the most important distinction is
really between people who just want to
be left alone to enjoy their hobby
consumers and and and fans of an
entertainment
medium and you know these broken middle
class white train wrecks who have
decided that the world is broken and
they're the only people who can fix it
well let me back it up a little bit
because you talk about social justice
warriors and sort of I guess and I know
Paul Joseph Watson uses the term third
wave feminism I use the term neo
feminism let's back it for people who
maybe don't know the story how are they
encroaching I guess on how are they
being authoritarian with with the gaming
industry a lot of people may not even
necessarily know how it started or what
the catalyst was because it was pretty
specific right sure to understand where
this is all come from you have to
understand first that gaming grew very
quickly and as a result you had a trade
press press that was religious catering
to the industry suddenly found itself
almost overnight becoming a consumer
press and these sites that had very low
quality journalism and very poor ethical
standards and were uniformly very
left-wing and they signed up to that
third wave feminists sort of
authoritarian Mitro microaggression safe
space man slamming kind of nonsense and
they almost uniformly signed up to that
suddenly found themselves the gaming
press establishment and it happened
almost overnight now these people are
almost without exception have bought in
entirely to the Anita sarkeesian view of
the world which is that that video games
can make you sexist in the real world
that's the issue here the question that
the question that needs to be answer
that nobody has satisfactorily given
evidence for us is this claim that video
games can somehow make you worse in the
real world now the press which have done
a really good job of defending video
games against charges of violence did a
really bad job against defending it
against charges of sexism and it was
sort of accepted that video games could
make you sexist and now the problem the
problem is that you know there's no
proof for that there's no evidence
there's no sign there's no scientific
study that shows that and what feminists
did is they've done so many times before
is they embarked on this campaign of
misdirection where they started to gin
up and then make a fuss about supposed
threats of you know rape threats death
threats so you know you name it there's
a classic strategy from the feminist
playbook and what it does is it shifts
the sympathy and attempt
on to the abuse claims and what you're
and sort of draws the eye away from
asking whether any of the claims that
those feminists are making in their
critiques are actually true or not right
so this sort of waved through almost I
mean this is this is a microcosm of a
problem at large particularly
particularly in the United States I
don't want to speak for the UK you can
speak more effectively to that but have
you been staying up to date on mattress
girl yes the lawyer yeah yeah I read the
complaint and it's horrifying but this
is a classic thing that feminists do you
know they claim abuse they claim
harassment they claim persecution they
claim claim anything it takes to draw
attention away from the original set of
claims they were making because what
they've learned is that by doing that
they they no longer have to really
justify the original points of view
people accept them as given because they
think well if you're being persecuted
and abused and threatened because of
this there must be something in it the
reality is there's nothing in it right
Jackie at UVA wasn't raped
mattress girl wasn't raped right the
gamergate critics have no validity
whatsoever in any of the arguments that
well they posited with mattress girl we
just wrote about that at the website
where basically the burden of proof is
entirely on the man to prove he's
innocent in these sort of I guess mock
college trials like okay we're gonna go
forward with these charges it was
brought some campus police I'm not
exactly quite clear about its it's all
written up in the reports that we have
on the website and they still said
listen there's nothing here this guy
probably isn't guilty the parents are
suing the school graduation was ruined
and even the Liberals were conceding now
saying well the left I say saying okay
maybe this was false but that's not the
point it's still a good thing because it
brought awareness to a really big
problem we don't have the numbers in the
problem mind you but the really big
problem of campus rape I mean honestly
one is for women you would believe that
just people I mean anyone with a penis
you and I are just going out and just
raping women by the throngs on campus to
hear it from the media well you know
these things don't even Steve even
survived a common sense test they
particularly don't survive any kind of
critical or academic inquiry so you know
you look at people like Christina of
summers in American Enterprise Institute
who very effectively and completely
demolished most of these claims whether
it's the gender wage gap which does not
exist whether it's
the rape crisis of rape culture on
campus which does not exist
you know this that this stuff is is
posited and then immediately you'll
notice in every case there's a
misdirection applied to it it says if
you count all drunken intercourse as
rape so they try and make it exist
that's the Astoria so I mean you know
I've written it quite extensively about
this sort of stuff I mean I'm I'm a homo
so I don't really have a I don't have
you know if you were just English or
what no no no both both English and gay
that's why sounds so posh you know I
don't have a dog in this fight but I've
written a lot about it because I see
what's happening to men and I see how
unfair it is and how you know many of
these ridiculous is a hostile
environment for men is driving men for
example out of the institution of
marriage because they realize it's no
longer a good cost-benefit for them it's
driving them out of society and into
porn and video games and all sorts of
other things I call it the sexy dose in
a big 2 P 2 part P so at last year you
know I see a lot of this happening and
it's very sad and what you notice is the
architecture of these events we can you
can always tell the cons first of all
because the collect the initial claims
are just too out too good to be true
like Sabrina early from Rolling Stone
went by her own admission so called rape
shopping she went looking for the most
outrageous and extraordinary rape she
could find something that would really
as I think the Daily Caller put it a
rape that would pop and of course what
happened is she found a liar and a liar
who would tell her whatever that she
whatever she wanted and then of course
the story became about how you know the
university tried to cover it up and
everybody was being so mean to her and
the original fact of the rape took quite
a while to come out it took a while to
realise that that was true
similarly with mattress girl you know
this ridiculous art stunt this this
attention-seeking turning herself into a
liberal here on the basis of a lie it's
done to deter to distract us from
finding out whether or not the original
claims were true at all now the reason
this is relevant gamergate is that yes
it is primarily first-lien for mostly
about press ethics because all of this
stuff is played out in an uncritical
press that takes the sign of the
feminists against reason against fact
against common sense and against their
own audiences these you know the potox
of people are upset about this stuff
don't play video games
they don't talk about video games they
don't care about video games there's
also people who talk about this stuff
are interested in winning culture wars
and what the journalists are now
beginning to realize is that you know
their audiences have almost entirely
abandoned them and that's where the
journalistic ethics come in I think that
these two issues are inextricably linked
because the part of the driving
motivation behind ethical failures and
video games journalism is social justice
ideology well that's why they do it
because they believe like Rolling Stone
believed that the narrative as you
suggested the narrative is more
important than the fact yes exactly and
the one thing that do hope that gamers
who may not who may have been entirely
closed off to I guess sort of what they
see is a libertarian or more right-wing
conservative ideology whatever you want
to call it we've talked about this in
the show you know Larry King we just
pulled this from an interview from a
podcast where he said you know I I don't
think the prep cable is as effective in
that used to be that the media can no
longer elect presidents and he said it
condemning media as though they should
have that ability what I hope we'll see
is that the same Republicans and the
Conservatives or whatever you call them
in the UK you guys are changing the
terminology all the time it's like
Quebec whatever they want to call them
who they vilified these are the same
people who've been fighting it out
against the press for decades saying hey
listen there is only one voice one point
of view in the press and that is the
voice of the politically correct
authoritarian authoritarian Thorat Aryan
or my mouth is going crazy right now
it's the establishment it's a voice of
the establishment here in United States
we've been fighting against it for a
long time and I hope people are waking
up to the fact that it really is an
issue it's not the boy who cried liberal
bias well I have some good news feel in
that front I think you're right I think
if for a long time it was possible even
to ordinary reasonable relatively
apolitical people to laugh at
conservatives when they said you know
well as as the great lady Thatcher says
you know reality has a well-known
conservative bias well the fact though
she said the facts of life are
conservative we know these things to be
true it was possible to laugh for
conservatives for a long time for these
things fandoms like gamergate are
discovering just what happens when you
start to buy into the authoritarian
establishment view and what I've seen
whatever your view on various right-wing
outlets whether it's
Daily Caller or Breitbart or Fox News or
whatever what I've noticed it
ordinarily happening is that you know
there's a thing in the in the men's
rights world red pilling you know you
sort of take the red pills and your eyes
are open to the realities of the
relationships between men and women and
how they should both behave and all the
rest of it I've noticed a similar sort
of effect in gamers where they suddenly
realize what actually wait I was I think
it was yesterday I saw a tweet somebody
said I just watched Fox New Year's and
for the first time in my life it's
starting to make sense to me
you know and of course a lot of them
have been coming to Breitbart to read my
stuff and I think there's obviously an
inevitable bleed into us we're on the
site and they're starting to realize
well these guys are not what I was
always told they were right now gamers
of course are are and will remain
reflexively left-wing people I think as
a function of the sorts of person who
gets into video games I don't think is
very much eager to change that but what
I think is really interesting and I
think again one of the reasons game gets
so interesting it's so important is that
gamers have had an open mind about this
they've combined a sort of ruthless
meticulous thoroughness in the way
they've conducted their letter-writing
campaigns with an open mindedness and a
sort of Socratic humility about
knowledge and about politics that I
haven't seen happen anywhere else they
haven't just thrown themselves into a
particular bucket or any particular
tribe as we are all want to do and
they've gone out and found out for
themselves what the facts of life and
the facts of the situation are unfair
and found liberal media desperately and
terribly wanting and you know I think
it's something that we've all known for
quite a long time but I don't think it's
going to be a mass exodus of gamers to
Fox News I think conservatives are just
just as much to blame for not listen I
can tell you this we have a pretty young
demo at lighter with credit calm we'd
have a decent demo anywhere else in the
realm of conservative media we have a
demographic that's unheard of they might
as well be a fetus's so feat I I don't
know at that point it would be fetuses
that's what I thought I have an
Englishman we went to the language yes
so just so you know it's not octopi it's
octopuses you know any others you just
bring it to me I got your back right but
that i before e rule except after C is
complete bull crap it doesn't apply at
all it's a terrible rule I will say this
conservatives are equally to blame and
it's not that their message it's not
that the principles are wrong it's the
packaging has been really tough there's
a huge section
of this this country and I think the
world now in a growing way me I have
fans now from Australia who never
Germany I candidate why I live in Canada
there were far leftists and far left to
separate us we have to go to a break and
we'll bring you right back on meelo your
novel a Greek name last name of
gamergate everybody we are back with
Milo before I so rudely cut him off made
a horrible grammatical and accuracy and
now we've brought him back you've got
the bleep chair going on it's kind of I
mean did you go in and say give me the
slim shadey or the My Chemical Romance
mm oh well no I don't really know oh I
know who slim Shady's I don't know who
my Chemical Romance's music for me is I
sort of pre 18 pre 1900 or like Mariah
Carey that's really all I know okay you
said you were a homo so now I have to
ask the Mariah Carey is that the gay
team Jersey for English people like
Celine is for the gay people in Quebec
yeah I mean it's just it's just
signaling really I'd say I like her I
have no idea if I really do knows I flew
to Berlin to buy her last album it
wasn't available in the UK cost me
twelve hundred fifteen hundred dollars
or something because I wanted to be the
first person to have the CD but I'm
pretty sure it's just a status thing is
that a joke or did you actually fly to
Berlin no I did that up you must've been
furious when you saw that video of when
they took off her backup band at the
Rockefeller Plaza in New York I don't
watch things like that because I can no
no no no I will not have her sullied in
that way okay well I mean I sort of
complicated Catholic it's the closest
thing I have to a deal to your notes
okay all right that's right wined it in
honey no as for the hair well you you
know you guys get Hartley's in your 40s
we expecting to die earlier get bleached
hair in our thirties so you know it's
just our version of a midlife crisis
okay well I hate Harley's and I've
gotten a lot of flack for its matter
back that was the least conservative
thing Reagan ever did was put tariffs on
Japanese bikes because in the 80s the
Japanese were making great motorcycles
and Harley's yeah that's pretty cool I
quite like that I'm quite into
protectionism
I'm not like the other people you have
on your show I'm like a problem we've
had actual terrorists on the show and
we've also had Dean Cain we've had Paul
Joseph ed Cain we have Superman yeah I
was so excited to discover that he was a
Republican because I grew up you watch
you call it Lois and Clark in America we
used to call it the new in Britain it's
called the New Adventures of Superman
and I grew up watching this show I grew
up watching two things I grew up
watching and forgive me for this I grew
up watching Star Trek Voyager I'm just
you know I guess just because that's
what was on okay I don't know well you
you're missing it homosexual I'm a
terrible perception yeah I'm such a
failure as a gay man I grew up watching
Star Trek I'm sorry but and the other
thing I was Lois Lois and Clark and I
found out that he was a a sound
Republican I was so happy
well yours you are so fortunate that fun
dip our producers not on right now
because he's a Trekkie
he also we won't let him live it down he
also said that he would sleep with a
transsexual man on air libertarian who's
just the and he loves all things British
you would do it well just for just for
fun you'd have to ask him we'll have you
back on and you can have said it was
that a male to female or a female when
he claims there's no longer a male if
it's male do you know do you know this
is that you know you know about ceilings
you know like this is a glass ceiling
women can't moving Collison beyond a
certain level in work it's called the
glass ceiling of their oppression no no
ceiling we're gone no it's called the
cotton ceiling and it describes the
inherent transphobia that all
cisgendered people have against
transsexuals it basically is it's a
transgender campaigners way of saying if
you do want to have sex with me you're
transphobic and it's called the cotton
ceiling supposedly because nobody gets
past the panties remember this is
dedicated to rest really careful now no
but not particularly a pleasant not a
particularly pleasant thing but no it's
my favorite my favorite kind of ceiling
as you as an English homo as you put it
I can't put it that way you did you're
worried about panty but hobo is fine
well yeah I mean how much I started well
I had a guy who actually was just
writing he's an intern and he like said
something he sent me something about
homosexual marriage I said well just say
gay marriage you're gonna walk into a
firefight you don't want but then you
use the word homo out now and I guess
it's one of those things you know no I'm
fine with it in fact if I wasn't gay I
would be a huge homophobe so it's really
fine
let me ask you this so where do you most
gay people and super progressive UK line
up like people like you want on the
transgenderism I mean that's a huge push
recently that's a recent push yes what's
happened with the transgender thing is
okay so I'll tell you what my position
has been and I'll tell you where I'm
being encouraged to go on this so my
position so far has been that it is a
horrible psychiatric disorder that
affects people to be better treated with
therapy and drugs rather than surgery
everyone who has surgery seems to regret
it afterwards or the suicide rates down
to the roof
well they don't improve some studies say
they get worse off the surgery we're
getting to the stage now where we have
been doing it for long enough that we
know that almost everybody that has the
surgery starts to have doubts about it
and if you look at the behavior of some
transsexual campaigners and look at the
other things they present with when they
show up at the doctors they very often
come it very often comes as part of a
cluster of disorders including
narcissistic personality disorder and
bipolar disorder it looks very much like
another one of those personality or
identity disorders that ought to be
treatable therapy and drugs we don't cut
off the arms of people who wake up one
day and say this arm doesn't belong to
me so we shouldn't become warp reality
to conform to delusion we should instead
trying to help that person reconcile
that their body with their mind has been
my position so far and as a result I got
really irritated and upset with again
with the media who decided to present it
what is a medical argument in which the
jury's still very much out as the next
civil rights struggle and they did this
for a number of reasons they did this
because by associating it with gays and
lesbians it provides a ready-made
pathway to as to what we should do about
it obviously they should be given this
obviously should be given that the prop
the trouble with transgenderism is
actually has nothing in common with gays
and lesbians whatsoever there's nothing
in common and it's the trans Lobby needs
to us to remember to needs to keep it as
a disease otherwise there's no
justification for state funding for
surgery so it's a very complex and very
difficult position for them to be in a
very horrible disorder where I'm
encouraged to move on this is that in
fact it is possible to be born with
brain in the wrong body that there are
plenty of very high-functioning and
perfectly happy people who have this
have this condition and the interesting
thing about it the thing that obviously
appeals to me it's not the basis on
which to make a decision but obviously
something that appeals to me as a as a
right-wing polemicist is that if you
accept as the left insists that we now
do that you can be born with the wrong
gendered brain that blows out of the
water gender is a social construct and
gender is a social construct has been
the central linchpin of the majority of
left-wing sexual thinking for the last
40 years if you throw out the idea that
gender is a social construct you throw
out the idea of that that all gender
roles are just performative and learned
behavior and you accept that somebody
can be born with the wrong brain a man
can be born with a woman's brain that
upsets the apple cart for the left-right
more than more than I can really explain
to you in the confines of this program
because what it does it suggests that
all of the wars they've been fighting
all of the sexism stuff they've been
talking about all of the sort of don't
tell me I can't behave like acts because
I'm a woman
is rubbish the head movement with your
impression how you think of all it was
like Mariah Carey it's my obnoxious head
what it does is suggests that everything
they've been arguing for the last 30
years is total hokum so the left has got
a pick one because you can't hold both
of these positions simultaneously right
cannot say there is such a thing as a
female brain and at the same time say
that all female behavior is learned and
in social and therefore we should stop
complaining that women about women who
don't want to be feminine and we should
we should say it's okay for men to be
metrosexuals and all the rest of it my
view is it isn't so I'm very tempted by
this view I'm very tempted by this new
position that I'm being encouraged it's
a good point I mean that point blows the
the wage gap out of the waters they go
well yes you're right it is because
women choose different professional
positions because they have different
priorities but that's because that's
exactly and if it's true if what they
tell us about transsexuals the
transgender sufferers is true if they
tell us that there is a female brain and
a male brain and there are you know the
scary speck
biological determinism rears its head
again it may be simply unanswerable that
women choose make different career
choices and therefore willingly earn
less money when you average that out
across the whole of society which is
what dissident feminists and right-wing
critics have been saying for decades
when asked you as a to be devil's
advocate here would you then have to be
more open-minded to what is not a
hateful a conservative view but a view
on complementarianism that inherently a
mom can provide something to a family
unit that a man can't and that a father
can provide something to a family unit
that a mom can't because that's a big
reason I absolutely believe that I've
always believed that it's right don't
support gay parenting I mean aside from
the gigantic volumes of domestic
violence in lesbian relationships
they're all kicking the crap out of each
other all day long that means yes yes
yes lesbian relationships that this
statistics on lesbian domestic violence
are astonishing I believe that entirely
from my anecdotal experiences at pearl
Pro ever everybody knows this to be true
anyone who's ever pretended to enjoy
women's football and shown up to a match
and see what they get on to it seen what
they get up to on the pitch I mean it is
anybody's got a very left-wing friend
who's had to go and pretend to find
women's football I have to say one thing
though one thing my wife gorgeous tall
blonde you know it's what society
determines to be beautiful no I've
always said this you know one thing I do
find about feminism and then I'll move
on to my point there is I was talking
with
with my producer about this is going to
sound terrible but feminists have taken
something that knows no discrimination
the male physiology my schwann sin' is a
veritable beauty weather stick you can't
trick it you can't beat this
lie-detector test
it doesn't care your race it doesn't
care your size it doesn't care what so
class there are objective standards of
beauty that both sexes you know well I'm
saying you the dump stick doesn't lie
well exactly you could be a member of
the KKK and if you watch that monster's
ball scene with with gosh I just forgot
her name I just released the wrong no no
she's white I'm talking about what a
please that woman uh-oh Halle Berry
Halle Berry yeah that's racist to me to
forgot her name anyway my I was going to
get to the point my sister my wife her
sister and her cuz
all played hockey you expect women's
hockey players like well there's a type
they're all just like her gorgeous tall
blond feminine and blue might be but
that might be a class thing it sounds
like it's a sort of elite University
sport no no it's not as a matter of fact
I'm speculating I don't know you're
entirely speculating you're incorrect
well I guess hockey isn't very big over
there no no I mean we just associate it
with sort of I mean we don't have any
good sports I mean we have soccer for
God's sake I mean you know we invented a
couple of decent things but no American
national sports by far the best thank
you so much for saying that real
football baseball basketball like I
can't get enough of any of them no God
it's for going on soccers for gays I
mean you know that match is gone forever
this is so boring like going to watch
football is to admire the men which and
they're there for mystifies me that the
audience is mostly male because what are
they all doing for 19 minutes is so
boring no no no no I can't deal with any
of that I'm American sports all the way
and we were going to get letters we have
to have you back and we have to have you
debate fund it because fun dip thinks
he's being open-minded in the
transsexualism argument and we can talk
about the cotton ceiling quite keen to
know what I want to know which way round
he's happy with if he's happy with both
ways around that's interesting one
complicating factor which I will tell
you before we get off transgenders so
that you're not your show isn't canceled
beauties no one can fire me so I know
isn't it great is great it's it's
wonderful our lives are not so bad
actually no no no what what interesting
complicating factor that I've do you
know with the number two obviously the
number one transgender cap of the world
is of course Thailand do you know the
number two is okay hold on let me
actually take a step take a guess and it
isn't Canada I know you're gonna say
it's Canada but it's not Canada okay
is it was it first office at the United
States in time on a country or a city a
country okay a country transgender
capital you know what I'm just gonna go
we've had already you're not gonna well
I'm gonna go Norma Donald and who wants
to be a millionaire where they told him
it was the not obvious answer so I'm
going to go with a complete non obvious
answer Iran who is it actually yes no I
swear I
I am a Christian honestly I have a Bible
right here swear on the good Lord thank
you I promise you I said where do you
where I have at least succeeded in
establishing and it was an unlikely
choice yes it is and the reason is that
of course with the death penalty
the passive not to get too into too much
icky detail but the passive gay partners
have sex changes so they present as
women so they don't get murdered so that
they're not strung up and hung from
cranes which suggests you that there can
be some quite there can be social
factors that influence quite a what you
would imagine to be quite a big surgical
life decision so it's a very complex
issue and we don't know everything about
it we're told by the establishment media
that we do know everything about it it's
a very interesting it's a very
interesting conversation to have that
nobody's really allowed to have an
immense tree media I would love to talk
to a producer about it because I'd be
interested to as somebody who's sort of
a junkie on the science of this stuff
I'd be interested to hear he finds
attractive or not and in which direction
because it's just it's an endlessly
fascinating subject that tells us so
much about ourselves and so much about
the world around us so much about human
sexuality yet we're not allowed to have
any of those really interesting
discussions we're not allowed to talk
about the science we're not allowed to
talk about what this might say about
human relationships or society or
anything else because the left has
decided that this it is a civil rights
issue that is the science that's what
you have to do as a result and that's
the real objection if I can you know if
there's anything if there's any
overarching theme in my work the
gamergate stuff with transgender stuff
it's the my primary objection to your
Thorat Aryan left is that it is
profoundly entering an anti-intellectual
it is profoundly and determinately
purposefully stupid it does not permit
discussion and debate of the most
interesting and important things in
human life the most important philosophy
the most important politics the most
important stuff that that defines us and
it helps us to relate to the world
around us it will not have those
discussions that's what I hate about it
that's what I think it really Rob's
ordinary people of now that you know
that's that's what I think is the real
the real objection aside from any
specific stupid argument they make it's
a very good point and it also brings up
a point I've talked about this a lot on
air I try and avoid the
you know that kind of bullcrap and in
this sense it's sort of an anti
sensationalist show and people said this
isn't going to play on radio low and
behold the people who approach just
about syndication wanted to start
controlling guests and said no you know
we're just gonna run this as a podcast
have a couple stations that carry us and
no one else has any control but they
love the sensationalist story and they
were always going you know Obama's evil
Nancy Pelosi's evil I said listen I
don't believe that most people are evil
I think most people generally probably
think they're doing good but we've hit a
point here and you just touched on this
you're talking about profound stupidity
I'm getting to the point where I believe
there is proactive orchestration and
manipulation because when you have
Barack Obama get up and he says you know
women are paid 77 cents on the dollar am
I supposed to believe that his advisers
don't have Google obviously I have to
disabuse you of this actually and I
think that it's even worse than you
think my instinct is always to to recoil
in horror from anything that sounds
remotely like a conspiracy theory which
is sort of journalistic instincts have
developed normally because it is a
conspiracy theory right I think that
what you're identifying you correctly
identified a phenomenon but I think
you're you're you're reaching for the
most obvious cause which is collusion
which is what gamergate supposed about
games journalists why do all these all
these articles come out the same day
saying gamers are dead attacking them
the problem wasn't so much collusion
although collusion was going on and
there was a private list and they worse
be walking in lockstep and there was
pressure from one publication to another
to remove forum content that did not fit
the approved list of discussion topics
but I think it's worse than that when
you have a sort of ossifies
establishment echo chamber you don't
even need collusion well you have need
people we have many so yeah I don't mean
to cut you off I do draw I agree with
you and that's that's always what I've
said I've said it since September on the
show since this show started but let me
ask you this do you honestly think that
Barack Obama doesn't know that's a false
step the 77 cents on the dollar the wage
gap I I believe that he knows that it's
false
I believe he says it anyway and this is
one of many reasons why I really detest
having left with people in government
because the fundamental fundamental a
dishonest okay but we don't agree on
that point he's not that stupid
no I don't think he is yeah and I used
to just say I don't think he's evil I
think he doesn't know better I believe
that it was because it was I think it's
that I think it's narrative over fact I
think it's the recent Obama says that
knowing it's wrong for the same reason
that Rolling Stone published the UVA
story right the ends justify the means
sir and I had to go Oprah and wrap it up
in a cliche she loves her sound bites
she's the most evil woman in the world
something for other show Tyler Perry is
going to write you an angry letter and
he's worth more than I think the entire
gaming industry now where can people
best find you Milo Twitter's probably
the best place I'm products on social
media so you can find me an at an arrow
you can always email me Milo kanopolis
net I love to hear from people and look
out for the book in summer in the summer
well you are moving along quickly with
that thank you very much Miller we will
have to have these events you know Milo
we'll have to have you back and knock
some sense into fund it thank you so
much appreciate it well I too was
Crowder we'll be back after this video
subscribe by clicking my face in this
box or the subscribe button for those of
you who have to read I don't know we can
do it in Braille at some point but if
you want to see the extended interview
click on the box next to me to go over
to Milo's channel where there's a 45
minute uncensored incredibly profane
from Milo's end portion of the interview
enjoy